it's great to welcome to the program
today dr. Marty Meharry who's at Johns
Hopkins surgeon and a New York Times
bestselling author his book the price we
pay what broke American healthcare and
how to fix it is available now on Amazon
I think a good place to start is what
did break American health care I mean
former Cigna executive wendell potter
writes in his very good book deadly spin
about how in the period between World
War 1 and World War 2 the US was sort of
headed in the direction of a system more
like many of the European systems but at
the time it seemed to German when we
were not getting along well with Germany
that plan was abandoned and that was
sort of the beginning of the plan and
the system that we have now how do you
see the crux of how we got to where we
are now well people have a lot of
opinions David on health care and
everybody has their own experience or
their interface even doctors we tend to
see it from our vantage point in our
specialty but if we look broadly at the
entire system and we actually are not
beholden to any particular special
interest or stakeholder and can talk
openly and honestly with a critical view
of the entire system it's really two
fundamental root problems number one
pricing failures and number two
inappropriate care or the
appropriateness of care if we look at
the loss of competition in health care
and how you can't get a price for basic
services people have a right to be angry
and when those services 20% of the time
are unnecessary which is what our
research from Johns Hopkins has shown in
a national survey of US doctors they say
21 percent on average of all medical
care is unnecessary testing even
procedures medications these are the two
fundamental areas that we can improve
and in the book the price we pay I tried
to find the disruptors nationally who
are actually fixing health care by
addressing these two underlying root
problems now there are different
philosophies that would have one person
here what you just laid out
and go in the direction of well the
solution would be total free-market for
profit let everybody shop and do exactly
whatever it is they want let the sort of
lazy fair approach fix the problem and
there are others who would hear what you
said and say oh no no we need a
completely different system we need one
actually where we can have bigger
parties negotiating on our behalf up to
and including the government through
some kind of single-payer system which
does one or the other strike you is the
best path forward to solve the two
problems you outline well to be very
honest David I actually think that
there's tremendous consensus in the
United States if we can lay out the
issues for what they really are
that price gouging is wrong and that
that price gouging happens today and it
will continue to happen if the
government is the payer and by the way
the government does not have a great
track record as being a very good
negotiator when you deliver a baby in
Boston you can have that done for $6,000
or 41 thousand dollars both at Harvard
hospitals there's no difference in
quality these are sometimes the same
doctors price gouging has sadly become a
way of doing business and if we can get
rid of the waste in the system that
entire spend that makes a lot of people
rich in health care but is wasted money
we could create an efficient
marketplaces and actually cut the waste
in a way that's bipartisan and it
retains the private health insurance
system and at the same time keeps the
healthy Medicare government payer system
going strong so it sounds like you're
saying you wouldn't necessarily want to
expand any government involvement you
would want to keep Medicare and maybe
Medicaid but you would want to improve
the for-profit health care system that
we have is that what I'm hearing well
look I applaud people who find Medicare
for all attractive because they want to
get rid of the waste the problem is down
the stream long term a hundred percent
of the time in every country around the
world including our own long-term
governments tighten the belt on health
care expenditures and you can be left
with a dilapidated system at ten
20 years if we want to cut the waste
which is where I think there's broad
consensus we can do that by creating
transparency within the system I open
the book the price we pay with a group
of doctors in the Washington DC area
that are gouging Medicare that are
taking advantage of the system that are
our taxpayers are funding a group of
doctors doing unnecessary procedures all
day long that will continue with
Medicare for all that doesn't stop so if
we if we just look at competition and
transparency we can actually reduce the
waste because I personally believe David
that we already spend enough money in
America to give everybody gold-plated
health care oh yeah there's no question
that we do I guess I'm not sure that I
agree with you because yeah okay so I
think if you say to basically any
American do you want to get rid of waste
in the healthcare system basically every
American would say yes I do want to get
rid of waste the problem is that many
Americans see profit in an area where
there is completely inelastic demand as
part of the waste that should be removed
there are people who see a system that
requires medical billing experts on both
the insurance side and the provider side
as a form of waste which we could get
rid of through some kind of government
centered program so I do agree with you
that waste is bad and Americans want to
get rid of it I don't think that there
is as much agreement as maybe you're
suggesting as to what constitutes that
waste though well if we can agree that
there's a tremendous amount of waste if
we can agree that walking into a New
York hospital and having a bill of
seventy thousand dollars is egregious
when the market price is six to seven
sure there's a tremendous amount of
waste there that can be cut without all
of the infighting that's partisan about
what's the great philosophy to dominate
health care these are this is the
low-hanging fruit in the system and
trust me nobody has been more aggressive
in fighting the profiteering philosophy
and medicine that has taken over and
ruined the medical profession in certain
pockets of America than me and my team
we go to hospitals we call out CEOs we
just did a giant
expose of hospitals that sue patients in
the state of Virginia a study that came
out this week in JAMA showed that some
hospitals about 10% aggressively take
their patients to court when they can't
afford their bill we have called them
out in the hospital that was the worst
offender announced they're going to stop
suing patients as a result of our work
in the NPR piece that ensued so we have
been calling out people that have been
using profit to take advantage of people
all across the country and you're
absolutely right it's wrong it erodes
the great public trust of our medical
profession right hospitals were built to
be a safe haven a refuge for the sick
and injured regardless of their race
creed or ability to pay that is the
Charter of most US hospitals many of
which were paid were built on charity or
built by churches or by land grants from
the community yes so let's I mean let's
focus in on that a little bit because
that may be something my audience
doesn't know about I think my audience
probably understands the philosophical
difference is sort of underlying the the
idea of these systems that we're talking
about talk a little bit about the fact
that there are lawsuits against patients
by hospitals talk about the wage
garnishment also that I think many in my
audience have no idea is even a thing
that hospitals do have mechanisms for
actually garnishing the wages of former
patients for unpaid medical bills sure
well my research team started looking at
the markup on medical bills identifying
extreme outlier facilities hospitals
even physicians who are charging 23
times more than what the Medicare
allowable amount is when we would
approach hospital CEOs around the
country and say ask them why are you
charging five times more than the next
hospital that sees the same case mix in
payer mix the answer was always well we
have secretly negotiated contracts with
insurance don't worry Marty nobody pays
those bills so we did some research and
found out no a lot of people are
expected to pay that bill in full and
those people are expected to pay that
bill and if they don't they're taken to
court and sued by a hospital and have
their paycheck garnished
or liens put on their homes and we found
one hospital that has sued 24,000 people
in a town that by census data has 28
thousand people living in it we went to
New Mexico and in the book the price we
pay
I visited some of these courthouses
where we found the courthouse
transformed into a taxpayer-funded
collections agency for the hospital
lives ruined I mean these are
hardworking Americans whose been
financially devastated right most people
don't live like you and I David right we
are relatively wealthy in the United
States right God's been good to me I
have a good life as a surgeon at Johns
Hopkins most of America has less than
500 dollars of cash in savings they live
a very different life and healthcare has
forgotten them and we refer to them as
if they've done something wrong like
they've been irresponsible and failed to
get health insurance no these people
have health insurance our research shows
that they're insured they're working the
most common place they work is Walmart
number two is US postal workers workers
at Lowe's nurses and housekeepers at
hospitals being sued by their own
facility we did the expose on Mary
Washington Hospital we're now looking at
UVA which gets taxpayer funding and
Sue's a lot of people Memphis bat the
Baptist system just highlighted in Pro
Publica in New Mexico so where's finding
hospitals around the country that are
violating the public trust of our great
medical profession we're calling them
out we're doing this at restoring
medicine org
and so far the first hospital that we
talked to has announced they're going to
stop suing patients would someone have
recourse to say that they were sort of
in a situation of duress when they were
in the situation where they sort of
agreed to receive certain treatment
because in certain emergency situations
or even urgent situations you're you're
not exactly sort of calmly stepping back
the way you would if you're thinking
about choices for buying a car and
making a decision you're in a situation
where a doctor says this is the
procedure you need then later you end up
getting sued for some
which which I would argue there is a
sort of analogous duress type of
situation is that recourse that these
sue lawsuit victims can can sort of them
try to employ yes but David to be honest
they're too scared they are served at
home by a sheriff's deputy that wakes
them up at 7:00 in the morning we found
in some cases and they're told come to
court and they come to court and aren't
asked a question do you owe this money
they're afraid of perjuring themselves
they don't really understand what's
happening they just say yes and then
they have to provide their routing
number and account number in the back of
the courthouse to the hospital who pulls
the money out of their savings or their
paycheck is garnished or Elena's put on
their home
we have been representing patients pro
bono as best we can I will list my name
as the medical expert on their case for
free and I will argue to the judge the
patient doesn't owe the money
I can't mow your lawn and charge you
fifty thousand dollars without a
contract there's got to be an agreement
many people are asking I want to know
the price of what it's gonna cost to
deliver a baby beforehand
sixty percent of medical care is
shoppable that is it's elective right no
one's suggesting we give you a price if
you get shot and need to have a heart
valve replaced in the trauma Bay okay
we're talking about elective care
hospitals can get their act together
physician groups health care the elite
the medical establishment and figure out
a way to do honest and fair transparent
billing to patients and give them a
price before the service many of these
patients sued asked for a price and
we're told the runaround a typical
runaround it's common in hospitals if
you are somebody paying out-of-pocket or
out-of-network which is a fast growing
group of Americans and you need to
deliver a baby don't you think you
should be able to look up what it costs
at different hospitals assuming it's an
uncomplicated delivery so we've argued
to the judges there is no valid contract
people come to us in a hospital under
duress they are stressed they're scared
right when I see a patient in the
emergency room or in my clinic with who
was told they have cancer
there is one emotion that dominates
their mind and that is they're petrified
they're scared we have historically been
a refuge for people when they are
hurting now we've got patients in the
community saying in Virginia one woman
said I'm at home and sick and scared to
go to the hospital they've sued me twice
that is violating this great public
trust that we've had and I think doctors
and nurses and everyone at a hospital
they're starting to speak up and we're
seeing this now with our restoring
medicine Facebook page and other venues
the book is called the price we pay what
broke American healthcare and how to fix
it it's available now on Amazon and
we've been speaking with the book's
author dr. Marty Macari thanks so much
for talking to us about this today great
to be with you David